this morning i woke up with a really
anxious stomach
just because i want to not make a
mistake
and i need some advice
[Applause]
i'm excited to have joja over today
because it's nice to have
that sound board this has just been like
such a whirlwind and if anybody
understands
it's you give me everything so and
falling for multiple people
i can get ahead of myself and start
thinking about like okay well how am i
gonna make a decision at the end of the
day and like you can't do
that is self-sabotage it is it really is
because you get so in your own head
you can't overthink it and it is the
hardest thing in the world
what is your fear at the end of it well
it's just i've done it before
i've been married i've done all this and
like i'm not just gonna get engaged with
someone just because you know it just
like feels right in the moment
i need to know that i want that to be my
forever it's a huge decision and i know
you don't want to do that again you
don't want to go through a marriage and
have it not work out so this is i mean
it's heavy it's big